ausgerechnet deutsche unternehmen planen
eine weitere spektakuläre mondlandung
das projekt mission to the moon eines
berliner startups wird beispielsweise
von audi und vodafone unterstützt und
schon im kommenden jahr soll das erste
privat finanzierte und unbemannte
raumschiff nach 384 1400 kilometern
reise auf den mond aufsetzen zwei rover
sollen dann den landeplatz der apollo 17
mission besuchen
wie sehen die pläne konkret aus und wie
realistisch ist das ganz herzlich
willkommen zum science fiction
ein verrücktes projekt so ein projekt
leiter von audi über die mission to the
moon ursprünglich hatten sechs
ingenieure und wissenschaftler im jahr
2007 die idee die erste private mond
mission ins leben zu rufen sie gründeten
ein unternehmen namens petit sein dass
das mittlerweile 46 mitarbeiter
beschäftigt der krasse plan eine falcon
9 rakete soll schon 2009 10 von cape
canaveral in florida auf in richtung
mond starten und die verantwortlichen
der mission to the moon backen
keineswegs kleine brötchen vergleichen
das ganze projekt mit dem
apollo-programm an dem über jahre hinweg
knapp 40.000 menschen getötet hatten
der fahrzeughersteller audi ist im jahr
2014 in die mission eingestiegen und
zuständig für die technische
unterstützung und die kommunikation über
das ganze projekt beispielsweise war das
unternehmen an der energieversorgung und
dem antrieb beteiligt und hat zudem dazu
beigetragen den rover leichter zu machen
sein name audi luna quattro der
mittlerweile sind noch 30 kilogramm
wiegt dazu ein sprecher für uns als audi
ist sehr stand das thema raumfahrt
einzusteigen raumfahrt ist das thema des
21 jahrhunderts und jetzt noch ein paar
details zum rover sein motor läuft auf
solar basis das heißt die energie wird
aus der sonneneinstrahlung gewonnen die
räder der leichtbaukonstruktion bestehen
aus aluminiumlegierung werden per 3d
druck hergestellt getestet wurden sie in
einem becken im vulkanland er hat
allradantrieb und soll mit der
landefähre alina tatsächlich über lte
mobilfunk kommunizieren dafür sitzt dem
wunder von tochter bell labs mit im boot
und vodafone plant ernsthaft ein
lte-netz auf dem mond aufzubauen und
somit eine kommunikationsinfrastruktur
für kommende mondmissionen anderer
unternehmen zu errichten klingt verdammt
nach einer großen marketing geschichte
aber das bestreiten die beteiligten
unternehmen und forschungsteams
hartnäckig demnach seien die
apollo-missionen nichts anderes als pr
gewesen und es sei lediglich darum
gegangen flaggen in den mondboden
zusammen heißt es in interviews ja man
habe natürlich schon gewisse erwartungen
an das projekt das am ende auch
nützliche ergebnisse und inspirationen
liefern
so heißt es von offizieller seite
inhaltlich sondern es dabei vor allem
darum gehen das lunar rover michael lrv
von apollo 17
das seit 50 jahren dort oben steht
wissenschaftlich zu untersuchen was ist
seitdem mit ihm passiert gibt es
mittlerweile staub auf dem fahrzeug und
sind die gurte bereits verrottet oder
noch als solche zu erkennen fragen über
fragen auf die die mission to the moon
seriöse antworten geben will natürlich
in live bildern die red bull nur um
nochmal eine marke zu droppen direkt zur
erde übertragen wird und na klar ist an
dieser stelle ganz klar festzuhalten
dass den verantwortlichen natürlich sehr
an einer weltweiten medienpräsenz
gelegen ist und selbst wenn die mission
scheitern sollte ist ihr eine gewisse
aufmerksamkeit natürlich nicht zu
verleugnen zurück zum inhaltlichen
insgesamt sind drei missionen geplant
die seien bereits fix gemacht alle
fracht plätze an bord von lande fairen
und rover bereits verkauft der käufer
der gesamten dritten mission ist
tatsächlich die europäische
weltraumagentur esa auf mehr als 200
millionen euro belaufen sich die kosten
dafür das ziel der dritten mission ist
übrigens der südpol des mondes wo der
rover ein liter wasser gewinnen soll das
dort vermutlich gefroren vorkommt auch
hier betonen die verantwortlichen die
große wissenschaftliche bedeutung zudem
habe das ganze projekt auch eine
botschaft an alle leute da draußen
zitat du kannst in den weltraum fliegen
und du kannst dein leben damit
bestreiten bevor die mission to the moon
dann tatsächlich auch startet gibt es
allerdings oft zu tun
die endmontage steht noch aus und auch
an der flugabwehr wird noch intensiv
gearbeitet zudem sollen vor dem start
noch analog test durchgeführt werden
ähnlich wie beim apollo programm als die
nasa komplette mission auf war bei
durchgespielt hat denn die bedingungen
auf dem mond sind nicht ohne seinen
boden ist 120 grad heiß und die sonne
strahlt erbarmungslos herab die
umgebungstemperatur des weltraums liegt
bei minus 270 grad celsius das müssen
die batterien des luna quattro erst
einmal aushalten
es wird sich also in der nächsten zeit
schon zeigen wie ernst man die mission
wirklich nehmen kann denn er ist alle
auch einen musk arbeitet mit
druck am selben ziel ja wenn ihr kein
video verpassen wollt denn das passiert
wenn ihr euch auf die abo box von
youtube verlasst dann sollte er ihr mich
bei den messenger whatsapp und so weiter
ändern das ganze geht gleich hier
dann werdet ihr von mir vor allen
anderen über die neuesten videos
informiert täglich und garantiert
außerdem solltet ihr unbedingt meinem
schwesterkanal folgen clixoom social and
media und wenn er ihn abonniert das geht
auch hier unbedingt nicht vergessen die
genau die glocke der vater täglich neues
aus der social media welt und ansonsten
würde ich euch noch dieses video
empfehlen da geht es auch um
mondmissionen ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran